iraq's political atmosphere is in crisis
and the parliament is in level that is
after a disagreement between rival
politicians has reached an intense point
supporters of shia cleric and
influential political leader mukhtar
have occupied the headquarters of the
parliament and they say they will not
leave until the demands are met their
demands include that the parliament
reject the nomination of muhammad
yasudani for prime minister sudhani was
nominated by the rival pro-iranian
parliamentary bloc the coordination
framework the crisis started in june
when 73 lawmakers affiliated to the
quoted the parliament after the
parliament failed more than once
to elect a new president of the state
or to elect a new prime minister to form
a new government assad and his
affiliates want to form a majority
government by
the majority of the lawmakers they say
they had the largest block in the
parliament so
that in their words gives them the right
to form a new government with their
sunni and kurdish allies on the other
hand the coordination framework
lawmakers say that a new consensus
government should be formed in order to
include all the various parliamentary
blocs
now the problem continues and the
supporters of all southern are in
control of the parliament many state
institutions
are not functioning and
suther himself in a recent televised
statement has commanded his supporters
to continue their sitting in the
parliament
until their demands are met he has also
suggested that the parliament be
dissolved and new or fresh
legislative elections be held in order
to solve this impasse
the current standoff has severely
impacted the
lives of civilians people in the streets
have been complaining
of that political deadlock they have
been relying
on
to be formed new government to handle
the multiple crises and to address
the
needs of the civilians but
there has been disillusionment there has
been frustration among civilians
due to the current political deadlock